what was in the mind of winston
churchill why did he think
that he could afford not to negotiate
in terms of supreme command the allies
were very lucky
because had the war
broken out when stanley baldwin was
prime minister i think britain would
have not done very well at all
it broke out when naval neville
chamberlain was prime minister
but quickly he began to bring people in
the cabinet
who advised him corrected him
educated him about what was going on
he still felt that there was some chance
of a negotiated
peace after the fall of france but on
may 10
1940 the day that germany invaded france
there was a radical change of government
winston churchill came in and
churchill was determined to not
surrender not negotiate
but not only fight the germans and the
italians
but defeat them now this was very
strange idea because
within three weeks there would just be
britain
and there would be all of occupied
europe so what was in the mind of
winston churchill why did he think
that he could afford not to negotiate
hitler had offered him a deal where he
said we will not invade or bomb you
and we will let you have your empire
just call off the war
and then hitler thought that he would
turn his attention then without a worry
over
either britain or the united states and
he could turn his attention
to the soviet union but churchill was
not just a romantic
he was a very brilliant guy who was
convinced
that the last minute armament of the
royal air force
given the fact and given the fact that
the royal navy was the largest navy in
the world meant
everybody took a deep breath they said
to themselves
for all of german's continental ground
power
land forces they cannot get across the
channel because
the british navy will sink it sink ships
from the german navy
and they do not have the ability to
achieve error
superiority over britain and therefore
they can't attack us
and churchill said well you know what we
we can't invade either
so there's going to be a standoff and
that standoff is going to favor
us because eventually authoritarians
like hitler
and stalin cannot trust each other
they'll have a falling out
and at some point they will fight each
other and that will be to
our advantage and at some point we
understand that either the japanese or
the germans or the italians will do
something stupid
and draw the united states into the war
churchill was already envisioning an
alliance that was to happen
a year and a half later of the soviet
union
the united states and the british empire
against the axis triad and they would
have enormous advantages in terms of
manpower population industrial strength
and uh geography and that's exactly what
happened
in america it's hard to think how we
would have been prepared
for pearl harbor without franklin
roosevelt by that i mean
the republican party was primarily
isolationist
and the democratic party was focused
on the great depression and so at this
time people were saying we cannot
invest in military expenses and armies
and navies and air forces
fdr along with a brilliant congressman
carl vinson
thought otherwise and fdr understood
that
wherever we were going to fight pacific
or european theaters we needed a navy to
transport
soldiers over there and to protect them
from coming over here
so in a series of naval acts in the late
1930s the carl vinson
naval act one two three and etc
we had on the books a
new pacific fleet about five times
larger
than was at pearl harbor and much better
characterized
by baltimore heavy cruisers essex
carriers
the iowa class battleships that was
already on
the books it was already budgeted before
we went in
to world war ii and fdr and sometimes kg
machiavellian fashion
was reassuring an isolationist nation in
1940 that it would not go to war
even though he was taking quite dramatic
steps to prepare it to go to war and
might even welcome
it going to war at the second world war
was ultimately a story of people
how people died and how people made
decisions that determine which side won
or lost
i think we can sum it up by the results
because the proof of the pudding
is always in the eating and when we look
at this vast
canvas of death that was the second
world war 65 million people
we have to ask ourselves why were they
able to be so successful in the war
and i think the answer is the united
states and
the british had an overarching principle
that they were going to find
ways to win the war and to wage it
with the least possible uh
injury to their own country's
populations and that was completely
diametrically opposed
to the axis powers war of aggression
where they thought that
we're super people we're going to just
destroy inferiors and if we lose people
it's a glorious thing to die during a
war or in the soviet union's idea that
all that matters is survival of the
soviet state millions do not matter if
the soviet principle the soviet project
survives
ultimately then the story of people
turns out to be
the brilliance of winston churchill and
franklin roosevelt
and leading the democracies not just to
war but to
a victorious war and
at very little cost in comparison to the
other belligerents
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and invite
you to explore our complete course
on the second world wars all of
hillsdale college's online courses are
free
and for everyone who loves to learn